hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
today we're gonna play some games on
both the iPhone 10's max and Samsung's
Galaxy S 10 plus to see if there are any
noticeable differences in the gameplay
experience on both phones so both phones
are at a hundred percent battery life
and we're gonna set the brightness to
around eighty percent so we're gonna
match them on both phones and we're
gonna see which one heats up the most
and how much battery is left after this
gaming session so let's get right into
it all right guys here we are in game on
the iPhone Tennis Max and as you guys
can see we're at a hundred percent
battery life we're at around eighty
percent brightness and at 50 percent
volume so let's go ahead and get into
the settings as you can see we're at
high 100% resolution 60fps so far
everything's super smooth the 60fps is
just amazing that's what I love about
playing on this iPhone just such a large
screen 6.5 inches not seeing any dropped
frames or anything like that so pretty
excited about this other upstairs dude
did I miss every single what so even
though the iPhone has the knotch
you can't really tell because like your
thumb is covering this section right
here so it's really not a big deal whoa
gotcha
come on my man
Oh someone's behind me Oh got him whoa
I'm starting to feel some warmth from
the back of the iPhone here it's not
getting too hot
it's definitely feeling pretty warm I
don't know if you guys noticed it but I
think the display got quite a bit dimmer
Oh 16th place there's a lot of people
fighting right here Oh what I hate about
the face while my friend
[Music]
oh no all right so it's been about
thirty minutes playing for at night
let's go switch over to asphalt 9 before
we do so let's check out the battery
life or at 83% after 30 minutes of
playing fortnight at around 80%
brightness Wow all right Kay so here we
are on the galaxy s 10 plus as you can
see we're on high-performance mode bring
this down 100% battery life around 80%
brightness as well for night is not
updated to include this top section of
the display so you're not gonna
experience what it looks like if the
camera cut out that's unfortunate the
first thing I noticed however is how
much lighter this phone feels just like
on the iPhone hi 100% 60 FPS so just
here in the lobby I can tell that more
sound is coming from the bottom speaker
right here it's not really balanced
evenly like the iPhone tennis max is
whoa there's some weird drop frames just
happen right there
whoa ah so it definitely doesn't feel as
smooth on the s10 Plus which kind of
sucks but it's not too bad you wouldn't
respect in that shot him in the face
gadem alright guys so it's been around
30 minutes playing fortnight and we're
sitting at 87 percent battery life right
full screen looks pretty good notch is
not too distracting finish line nice the
stereo sound quality is really nice on
here I'm surprised let's go on this
thing nice finished quite a bit ahead Oh
unlocked man okay let's do this oh man
oh I did that on purpose guys finish
line I can't see anything
ooh knock down trying to make sure you
guys can see
oh no and that's quick nice guys you
should definitely check out this game if
you're like racing games so it's only
been about 10 minutes playing this game
we're at 77% battery life not too bad
alright here we go
asphalt 9 and the first thing I'm
noticing is that the screen looks
brighter looks more colourful looks
really good alright guys so I'm noticing
this sound quality is a little bit more
punchy it's seems louder even though
it's at 50% all right you guys calm down
oh nice to me it seems like there's some
dropped frames in this game compared to
the iPhone it's like a little bit laggy
tiny bit of lag just really weird Oh
would you guys see that
third place it's not too bad Oh knock
down I think I finally won yes feels
really good on this phone - just a
little bit of lag I didn't notice any
lag on the tennis max a little bit of
lag but it's not too bad still playable
great game
looks like everybody sucks at this game
especially me yeah yeah I got up nice
and bright I'm not getting any dimming I
think that was like a four night issue
then seven kills one death for my first
match got him oh I actually killed him I
have like no HP oh come on oh you guys
see that come on brother
watch this dude oh yes I killed him got
him got one guy all right guess we've
been playing on the iPhone tennis max
for just about an hour and we're at 68%
battery life so that's actually quite a
bit for only an hour of gameplay but we
are at 80% brightness so not too bad
let's see how the s10 place FPS set to
60 render scale 75 just like on the
iPhone 10 it's max optimal the same
exact settings
I got one guy nice throw some maids up
see if we can kill somebody
explosive kill got him got him
no one aide don't a Nate I need man come
on look at that I got the final kill
well I can definitely hear more from the
right side and it's nice that it's the
full display you can see the little
camera cut out it's actually not very
distracting and at all it's like you
don't even see it
the knotch on the iPhones pretty large
so it does distract you from the game
but this it's like your mind kind of
blocks it out so far the game feels
really good I'm not seeing any drop
frames or anything like that
plays very smooth oh you see that just
got to guys
got your back man got him
got him in terms of heat it actually is
not too hot either
come on bro got him we got you all right
so now I switched my gun whoa oh you
just got knifed got him all right guys
so there you have it it's been exactly
an hour on the s10 plus and we are
sitting at wow if I can ring this down
78% battery life Wow that's actually a
really decent difference between this
and the tennis max I mean I'm really
surprised all right guys so there you
have it and as you guys saw the galaxy
sn+ finished with 78% battery life and
the iPhone 10s max finished with 68
percent battery life so the galaxy is
definitely better in terms of battery
life during gaming I also noticed that
the tennis max got a little bit warmer
than the s10 did and I'm not sure if
that's the reason for the dimming during
fortnight maybe that's just a bug
because the other two games are totally
fine but all in all I think the display
looked a little bit brighter and nicer
on the s10 plus and for the speakers I'd
give it to the tennis max because they
were more balanced but they were pretty
punchy on sn+ I also noticed quite a few
drop frames in fortnight and in the
racing game on the SN plus but with the
tennis max it was perfectly smooth
throughout all the games that we tested
so what do you think which phone do you
think performed better and gaming thanks
for watching and make sure to subscribe
by hitting that button above and we'll
see you in the next video